well that's the koto drummers
about 30 or 40 Japanese
who live in a village on some island off
the coast of Japan and preserve
traditional Japanese music it's an
unusual semi communal group they
generally run about ten kilometers
before breakfast which is served at five
a.m.
strange group wouldn't miss a concert
for the world elderly alas don't seem to
be coming down my to to to the Boston
area very soon if you if you go to a
concert from the koto drummers and you
should and if you are no longer young
you'll want to bring earplugs because as
as we humans get older the dynamic range
control in our inner ear tends to be
less effective so that's why a person of
my age might find some piece of music
excruciating ly loud whereas you'll
think it's just fine because you have
better automatic gain control just like
enough any kind of communication device
there's a control on how intense the
sound gets ah but I go off on a sidebar
many of you have looked at me an
astonishment as I drink my coffee and
you doubtlessly been saying to yourself
you know Winston doesn't look like a
professional athlete but he seemed to
have no trouble drinking his coffee
so today's material is there going to be
pretty easy so I want to give you the
side problem of thinking about how it's
possible for somebody to to do that how
is it possible how did you make a
computer program that could reach out it
drink a cup of coffee don't want it a
cup of coffee so that's one puzzle like
it work out there's another puzzle to
that puzzle concerns diet drinks this is
a so-called diet coke
that's right if you take a diet coke and
ask yourself what would a dog think a
diet coke is for that's another puzzle
that you can work on while we go through
the material of the day so this is our
first lecture on learning and I want to
spend a minute or two in the beginning
talking about the lay of the land and
then we'll race through some material on
nearest-neighbor learning and then we'll
finish up with a discussion with the
advertised discussion of sleep because I
know many of you think that because
you're MIT students you're pretty tough
and you don't need to sleep and stuff
and we need to address that question the
force before it's too late of the
semester to to get back on track alright
so here's the story now the way we're
going to look at learning is that there
are two kinds there's this kind and
there's that kind and we're going to
talk a little bit about both kinds the
kind on the right is a regular is
learning based on observations of
regularity and computers are
particularly good at this stuff and
amongst the things that we'll talk about
in connection with regularity based
learning our today's topic which is
nearest neighbors then a little bit
downstream we'll talk about neural nets
and then somewhere near the end of this
segment we'll talk about boosting and
these ideas come from all over the place
in particular the stuff we're talking
about today nearest neighbors is the
stuff of which the field of pattern
recognition
it's the stuff of which
pattern-recognition journals are filled
this stuff has been around a long time
does that mean it's not necessary that
mean it's not good I hope not because
that would mean that everything you
learned in 1801 is not good because the
same course was taught in 1910 so it's
not it's been around a while but it's
extremely useful and it's the first
thing to try when you have a learning
problem because it's the simplest thing
you always want to try the simplest
thing before you try something more
complex that you will be less likely to
understand
so that's nearest neighbors and pattern
recognitions and the custodians of
knowledge about neural nets well this is
sort of attempt to mimic biology and
I'll cast a lot of calumny on that when
we get down Erica talked about it
and finally this uh this is the gift of
the theoreticians so we and AI have
invented some stuff we've borrowed some
stuff we've stolen some stuff we've
championed some stuff and we've improved
some stuff that's why our discussion
learning will reach around all these
topics
that's regularity based learning and you
can think of this as the as the branch
of bulldozer computing because when
doing these kinds of things a computer
is processing information like a
bulldozer processes gravel now that's
not necessarily good model for all the
kinds of learning that we humans do and
after all learning is one of the things
that we think that characterizes human
intelligence so if we're to build models
of it and understand that we have to go
down this other branch too and down this
other branch we find learning ideas that
are based on constraint now let's call
this the human-like side of the picture
and we'll talk about ideas that they
enable for example one-shot learning
where you learn something definite from
each from each experience and we'll talk
about explanation based learning by the
way do you learn much by self
explanation I think so an advisee once
we've got nothing but A's and EPS and I
said what are the subjects you get A's
in and why don't you get a is in all of
your subjects and he said oh I get A's
in the subjects when I convince myself
the material is true so the learning was
a byproduct of self explanation some
kind of important kind of learning but
alas that's that's downstream and what
we're going to talk about today is this
path through the tree nearest neighbor
learning and here's how it works in
general there is or here's just a
general picture of what we're talking
about when you think of pattern
recognition or nearest neighbor based
learning you've got some sort of
mechanism that generates a vector of
features so we'll call this the feature
detector and out comes a vector of
values and that vector of values goes
into a comparator of some sort
and that comparator compares the feature
vector with feature vectors coming from
a library of possibilities and by
finding the closest match the compare
tour determines what the object what
some object is it does recognition okay
so let me demonstrate that with these
electrical covers suppose they arrive on
an assembly line and some robot wants to
sort them how would it go about doing
that well it could easily use a nearest
neighbor sorting mechanism so how would
that work well here's how it would work
you would make some measurements and
we'll just make some measurements in two
dimensions and one of those measurements
might be the total area including the
area of the holes of these electrical
covers just so you can follow what I'm
doing without craning your neck you see
if I can find the electrical covers yes
now they are so we've got one big blank
one several others so we might also
measure the whole area and this one here
this this guy here this big black one
has no whole area and it's got the
maximum amount of total area so it will
find itself at that point in this space
of features then we've got the guy here
with room for four sockets in it that's
got the maximum amount of hole area as
well as the maximum amount of area so
it'll be right straight up maybe up here
then we have in addition to those two a
blank cover like this it's got about
half the total area than any other than
any cover can have so
put it right here and finally we've got
one more of these guys oh yes this one
half the whole area and half the total
area so I don't know let's see where
will I go maybe about right here so now
our robot is looking on the assembly
line and it sees something coming along
and it measures the area and of course
there's noise there's manufacturing
variability so it won't be precisely on
top of anything but suppose it's right
there well it doesn't take any genius
even our computer to figure out that
this must be one of those guys with
maximum area and maximum hole area but
now let's ask some other questions where
would where would a what would that be
or what would this be and so on well we
have to figure out what those newly
viewed objects are closest to in order
to do an identification but that's easy
we just calculate the distance to all of
those all those standard Platonic ideal
descriptions of things and we find it I
know which is nearest but in general
it's a little easier to think about
producing some boundaries between these
various idealize places so that we can
just say well which area is the object
in and then we'll know it
instantaneously to what category it
belongs so if we only had to like the
purple one and the yellow one it would
be easy because we're just going to
construct a line between the two with
the line between the purple and yellow
is a perpendicular bisector and so
drawing it out instead of talking about
it if there were only two that would be
the boundary line anything south of the
dotted line
the purple and anything north would be
yellow and now we can do this with all
the points right so we can figure out Oh
could you Pierre could you just close
about cut please so if we want to do
this with all these guys it would go
something like this
I better get rid of these dotted X's
before they confuse me let's see we got
if these were the only two points then
we want to construct a perpendicular
bisector between the line joining them
and if these two are the only points I'd
want to construct this for a particular
bisector and if these two were the only
points I want to construct a
perpendicular bisector and if these two
points we're the only ones involved I'd
want to construct oh you see what I'm
doing I'm constructing perpendicular
bisectors and and those are exactly the
those are exactly the lines that I need
in order to divide up this space and
it's going to divide up like this and I
won't say we'll give you a problem like
this on an examination but we have every
year in the past had to divide up a
space and produce what we would like to
give something we would like to give a
name you know Rumpelstiltskin effect
when you have a name you get power over
it so we're going to call these decision
boundaries okay so those are the simple
decision boundaries produced in a simple
space by a simple idea but there is a
little bit more to say about this
because I've talked about this as if
we're trying to identify something
there's another way of thinking about it
that's extremely important and that is
this suppose I come in with a brand new
cover never before seen and I only
measure
well let's say I only measure lets they
only measure the whole area and the
whole area is has that value what is the
most likely total area well I don't know
but there's a kind of weak principle of
if something is similar in some respects
it's likely to be similar in other
respects so I'm going to guess if you
hold a knife to my throat and back me
into a corner that its total area is
going to be something like that orange
cover whole sole area so this is a
contrived example I don't make too much
of it but what I do want to make a lot
of the of that first principle over
there and that is the idea that if
something is similar in some respects
it's likely to be similar in other
respects because that's what most of
education is about fairytales legal
cases medical cases business cases if
you can see that they're similar in some
respects to a situation you've got now
and it's likely that they're going to be
similar in other respects as well so
when we're learning we're just not not
just learning to recognize a category
we're learning because we're attempting
to apply some kind of precedent that's
the story on that well that's a simple
idea but that doesn't have any
application the answer is sure well
here's an example my second example the
the example of cell identification
suppose you have some white blood cells
what might you do you might measure the
total area of the cell and not the whole
area but maybe the nucleus area and
maybe you might measure four or five
other things and put this thing in a
high dimensional space you can still
measure the nearness and a high
dimensional space so you can use the
idea to do that it works pretty well
friend of mine once started to cut me
based on this idea he got wiped out of
course but it wasn't his fault
what happened is that somebody had been
in the
Stane and was became much easier to just
to the recognition by brute force so
let's see huh that's two examples the
introductory example of the holes of the
electoral covers and the example of
cells and what I want to do now is show
you how the idea can reappear in
disguise forms in areas where you might
not expect to see it so consider the
following problem you have a collection
of articles from magazines and you and
you and you're interested in learning
something about how to address a
particular question how do you go about
finding the articles that are relevant
to your question so this is this is a
puzzle that has been studied for decades
by people interested in information
retrieval and here's the simple way to
do it I'm going to illustrate once again
in just two dimensions but it works and
has to be applied in many many
dimensions the idea is you count up the
words and the articles in your library
and you compare the word counts to the
word counts in your probing question
alright so there might be you might be
interested in 100 words I'm only going
to write two on the board for
illustration so we're going to have
we're going to think about articles from
two magazines well first of all what
words are we going to use one word is
going to be hacked and that will include
all derivatives of hack hacker hacking
and so on and the other word is going to
be computer
and so it would not be surprising for
you to see that articles from Wired
magazine might appear in places like
this they would involve lots of uses of
the word computer and lots of uses of
the word hack and now for the sake of
illustration the second magazine from
which we are going to draw articles is a
Town and Country it's a very Toni
magazine and the people who read Town &
Country tend to be social parasites and
they they still use the word hack
because you can talk about hackings
there's some sort of specialized term of
art and dealing with horses so all the
Town & Country articles would be likely
to be down here somewhere and maybe
there would be one like that where they
talk about hiring some computer expert
to keep track of the results of the data
of the weekly hunts or something and now
then you come with your probe and of
course your probe question is going to
be relatively small it's not going to
have a lot of words in it so here's your
here's your probe question here's your
unknown which article is going to be
closest which articles are going to be
closest well alas all those Town &
Country articles are closest so you
can't use the nearest neighbor idea it
would seem anybody got a suggestion for
how we might get out of this dilemma yes
oh brother
using decision boundaries that our
processors have you treated like wires
and tons of geezers of this certain
parties routers oh here we go
we're going to use an including distance
metric we're going to some other metric
let me give you a hint
let me give you a hint there all those
articles up there out there and out
there just for example and here are the
Town & Country articles are out there
and out there for example and now our
unknown is out there and I got an idea
now hey Brad what do you think
let's be off there we go we're getting a
horse biscuit
the nectar is good so various different
metric what we're going to do is we're
going to forget about Euclidean distance
and we're going to measure the angle
between the vectors so the angle between
the vectors well let's actually measure
the cosine of the angle between the
vectors and see how we can calculate
that so we've take the cosine of the
angle between the vectors we'll call it
theta that's going to be equal to the
sum of the of the unknown values times
the article values those are just the
values in various dimensions and then
we'll divide that by the magnitude of
the other vectors so we have will divide
by the magnitude of U and we'll divide
by the magnitude of the art vector to
the article so that's just the dot
product right that's a very fast
computation so with a very fast
computation you can see if these things
are going to be in the same direction by
the way if if this vector here is
actually identical to one of those
articles what will the value be well
then the cosine will be zero and we'll
get the maximum guy of the cosine which
is one what if yeah that'll do it so if
we use any of the articles to probe the
article space they'll find themselves
which is a good thing to have a
mechanism do okay so that's just the dot
product for those two vectors and it
works like a charm it's not the most
sophisticated way of doing these things
there are hairy ways you can get a PhD
by doing this sort of stuff in some new
and sophisticated way but this is a
simple way it works pretty well and you
don't have to strain yourself much to
implement it so that's cool that's an
example where we have a very
non-standard metric
now let's see what else can we do how
about a robotic arm control here we go
here's we're going to just have a simple
arm and what we want to do is we want to
get this arm to move that ball along
some trajectory at a speed velocity and
acceleration that we become it so we've
got two problems here well let's see
we've got two problems because first of
all we've got angles theta one and theta
two it's a two degree of freedom arm so
there are only two to two angles so the
first problem we have is the kinematic
problem of translating the XY
coordinates of the ball the desired ones
into the theta one theta two space
that's simple kinematic problem no F
equals MA there it doesn't involve
forces or time or acceleration anything
pretty simple but then we've got the
problem of getting it to go along that
trajectory at us you know with positions
speeds and accelerations that we whether
we desire and now you say to me well
I've had 801 I can do that and that's
true you care because it's Newtonian
mechanics all you have to do is solve
the equations
there are the equations good luck why
are they so complicated well because of
the complicated geometry you notice
we've got some products of theta 1 and
theta 2 in there somewhere I think you
got theta twos
I see acceleration squared and yeah
there's a theta 1 dot times theta 2 dot
velocity times the velocity where the
hell that come from I suppose be F
equals MA right so the Coriolis force is
because of this complicated geometry
okay so you hire a Berthold horn or
somebody to work these equations out for
you and it comes up with something like
this you try it out doesn't work why
doesn't it work
it's Newtonian mechanics I said it
doesn't work because we forgot to tell
bertholle there's friction and all the
joints and we forgot to tell them that
they weren't a little bit since
yesterday and we forgot that the
measurements we make on the lab table
are not quite precise so people tried to
do this and just doesn't work you know
as soon as you get a ball of a different
weight you have to start over it's gross
so so I don't know I I can do this sort
of thing effortlessly and I couldn't
begin to solve those equations so let's
see what we're going to do is going to
forget about the problem for a minute
now we're going to talk talking about
building ourselves a gigantic table and
here's what's going to be on a table and
table theta1 theta2 theta3 whoops oh
they're only two so that's theta one
again but it's the Becht is the velocity
angular velocity and then we have the
accelerations
so we're gonna have a big table of these
things what we're going to do is we're
going to give this arm a childhood and
we're going to write down all the
combinations we ever see every 100
milliseconds or something and the arm is
just going to wave around like a kid
does and a cradle and then we're not
quite done because the two other things
we're going to record and guess what
they are they're going to be the torque
on the first motor and the torque on the
second motor and so now you've got a
whole bunch of those records and the
question is what are we going to do with
it
well here's what we're going to do with
it we're going to divide this trajectory
that we're hoping to achieve up into
little pieces and there's a little piece
and in that little piece nothing is
going to change much there's going to be
an acceleration velocity position and so
we can look those up in at it in a table
that we made in a childhood and we'll
look around and find the closest match
and this will be the set of values for
the positions velocities and
accelerations that are associated with
that particular movement and guess what
we can do now well we can say in the
past the torques associated with that
particular little piece of movement lie
right there so we can just look it up
now this method was thought up and
rejected because computers weren't
powerful enough and then this is the age
of recycling right so the idea got
recycled when computers got strong
enough and it works pretty well there's
things like this but you might say to me
well going to do this stuff that we
humans could do like this
and the answer is let's look so this is
the training phase it's going through
his childhood
you see what's happening is this the
initial table won't be very good but
that's okay because there are only a
small number of things that it's
important for you to be able to do so
when you try those things it's still
writing into the table so the next time
you tried that particular motion it's
going to be better at it because it's
got better stuff to interpolate so monks
in that table so that's why this thing
is getting better and better as it goes
in
good as I was doing
pretty good though I think there's just
one thing I want to show you at the end
of this clip it's just for fun maybe
you've seen some old Zorro movies so
here's a little setup where this thing
has learned to use a lash so here's the
lash and there's a candle down there so
watch this
pretty good don't you think so how fast
is the learning take place let me go
back to that other slides and show you
so here here's some graphs to show you
how fast that goes oh that gives you the
curve of the purpose of how well the
robot arm can go along a straight line
after no practice with just some stuff
recording the memory and then with a
couple of practice runs that give it
better better values amongst which to
interpolate so that's I think that
that's pretty cool so simple but yet so
effective but you still might say well I
don't know it might be something that
can be done in special cases I wonder if
Winston uses something like that when he
drinks his coffee well we ought to do
the numbers and see if it's possible but
I don't want to use coffee it's the
baseball season we're approaching the
World Series we might as well talk about
professional athletes so well let's
suppose that this is a baseball pitcher
and I want to know how much memory I'll
need to record a whole lot of pitches is
there a good pitcher these days the Red
Sox suck so I don't that sucks
clay Buckholtz I guess I don't know some
pitcher and what we're going to do is
we're going to say for each of these
little segments we are going to record
100 bytes for joint and we you know we
got joints all over the place I don't
know how many are involved in doing a
baseball pitch but let's just say that
we have a hundred joints and then we
have to divide the pitch up and do a
bunch of segments so let's just say sake
of argument that there are a hundred
segments
and how many pitches is a pitcher throw
and day what a day yeah this we all know
is about a hundred everybody knows that
they take them out after about a hundred
pitches so what I wanna know is how much
memory we need to record all the pitches
a pitcher pitches in his career so we
still have to work on this a little bit
more how many days a year does a pitcher
pitch well they've got winter ball and
that sort of thing so let's just
approximate it as a hundred I know some
of these may be a little high some of
the others may be a little low and of
course the career just to make things
easy a hundred years so that's a one two
three four five six so we have ten to
the twelfth bytes is that hopelessly big
to store in here
100 pitches in a day and we're going to
record Chris was asking some detail what
we're going to do is we report
everything there is to know about one
pitch and then we're going to see how
many pitches he pitches in his lifetime
and we're going to record all that okay
so we want to know if this is actually a
practical scheme and this by the way is
cocktail conversation who knows right
but it's useful to work out these
numbers and know some of these numbers
so question we have to ask is how many
how much computation is in there and
first question irrelevant to that is how
many neurons do we have in our brain
volunteer neuroscience no one but
volunteer all right well this is a
number you should this is a number you
should know because this is what you got
in there there are 10 to the 10th
neurons in the brain of which 10 to the
11th are in the cerebellum alone what
the devil do I mean by that I mean that
your cerebellum is so full of neurons it
Dwarfs the rest of the brain so if you
exclude the cerebellum you've got about
10 to the 10th of neurons and there are
about 10 to 11th neurons in the
cerebellum alone what's the cerebellum
for motor control hmm interesting so
we're a little short oh but we forget
that's just a number of neurons we have
to count up the number of synapses
because conceivably might be able to
adjust those synapses right so how many
synapses does a neuron have the answer
is it depends but the ones in the
cerebellum I should be pointing back
there I guess 10 to the fifth so if we
add all that up we have 10 to the 16th
no problem
it's just an existence proof you don't
have to worry too much about having
enough story so maybe our cerebellum
functions in some way as a gigantic
table and that's maybe how we learn
motor skills by filling up that table as
we run around emerging from the cradle
learning how to manipulate ourselves as
we as we go on so that's a story on
unarmed control now all this is uh all
this is pretty straightforward
easy to understand and of course there
are some there are some problems
problem number one
what if the space of samples looks like
this what's going to happen in that case
well what's going to happen in that case
is that the let's see which values are
going to be more important the X values
right the Y values are spread out all
over the place so you like the spread of
the data to sort of be the same in all
the dimensions so is there anything we
can do to arrange for that to be true
sure we could just normalize the data so
we can borrow from our statistics course
and say well let's see we're interested
in X and we know that the variance of X
is equal to 1 over N times the sum of
the values minus the mean value squared
that's a measure of how much the data
spreads out so now instead of using X we
can use X prime which is equal to 1 over
Sigma the which is equal to X over Sigma
what's the variance is that going to be
x over Sigma sub X anybody see
instantaneously what the variance are
that's going to be what do we have to
work it out everyone work at work out
the algebra for me this is obvious it's
simple just substitute
ex-prime into this formula for the
variance and do the algebraic highschool
manipulation you'll see that the
variance turns out now to be of this new
variable this transform variable 1 so
that problem
the the non-uniformity problem the
spread problem is easy to handle now
what about that other problem no cake
without flour what if it turns out that
the data you have two dimensions and the
answer actually doesn't depend on Y at
all what will happen then you're going
to get all your often I get screwy
results because it will be measuring a
distance that is merely confusing the
answer right so problem number two is
the is the what matters problem problem
number three write it down what matters
problem number three is what if the what
if there what if the answer doesn't
depend on the data at all then you got
the note you've got they're trying to
build a cake without flour once somebody
asked me and a classmate of mine who
went on to become an important executive
and an important credit card company
asked me if we could use artificial
intelligence to determine when somebody
was going to go bankrupt and the answer
was no because the data available was it
was data that was independent of that
question so he was trying to bake a cake
a flower you can't do that
all right so that concludes what I want
to say about nearest neighbors now I
want to talk a little bit about sleep
now over there on that left side branch
now disappeared we talked about the
human side of learning
and I said something about one shot an
explanation based learning and what that
means is that you don't learn without
problem-solving and the question is is
how is problem-solving related how much
sleep you get and that answer questions
like that of course you want to go to
the people who are the custodians of the
kind of knowledge you're interested in
and so you would say who are the
custodians of knowledge about how much
sleep you need and what happens if you
don't get it
and the answer is the United States Army
because they're extremely interested in
what happens when you cross ten or
twelve time zones have no sleep and have
to perform so they're very interested in
that question and they got even more
interested after the first Gulf War
which was the most studied war in
history up to that time because there
were after-action reports that were full
of examples like this the US forces in a
certain part of the battlefield had
drawn up for the night and those are
Bradley fighting vehicles there and back
here Abrams tanks and they're all just
kind of settling down for a good night's
sleep they've been up for about 36 hours
straight by the way when much to their
amazement across their field of view
came a column of Iraqi vehicles and both
sides were enormous ly surprised a
firefight broke out the lead vehicle
over here on the Iraqi side caught on
fire so these guys in these Bradley
fighting vehicles went around to
investigate whereupon these guys started
blasting away in acts of fratricidal
fire and the interesting thing is that
all these folks here swore in the
after-action reports that they were
firing straight ahead and what happened
was their ability to put ordnance on
target was not impaired at all their
idea of where the target was what the
target was whether it was a target was
all screwed up
so this led to a lot of experiments in
which people were sleep-deprived and by
the way you think you're tough MIT
student right these are arming Rangers
that it doesn't get any tougher than
this believe me
so what here's one of the experiments
was performed in those days they had
what they call fire control teams and
their job is to take information from an
observer over here about a target over
here until the the artillery over here
where to fire so they kept some of these
folks up for 36 hours straight and after
36 hours they all said we're doing great
and at that time they were bringing fire
down on hospitals mosques churches
schools and themselves because they
couldn't do the calculations anymore
after 36 hours without sleep and now you
say to me well I'm an MIT student I want
to see the data so that's how I look at
the data
okay so there goes that's what happens
to you after 72 hours without sleep
these are simple things to do simple
things to very simple calculations have
to in your head like adding numbers
spelling words and things like that so
after 72 hours without sleep your
performance relative to what you were at
the beginning is about 30% so loss of
sleep destroys ability
sleep loss accumulates so you say well I
needed hours of sleep and I what you
need by the way berries but I'm going to
get by with seven hours of sleep so
after 20 days one hours worth of sleep
deprivation you're down about 25% if you
say well I only need I need eight hours
of sleep but I'm gonna have to get by
with just six after twenty days that
you're down to about 25% of your
original capability so you might say
well this caffeine help our naps naps in
this case and the answer is yes a little
bit some people argue that you get more
effect out of the sleep that you do get
if you divide it into two Winston
Churchill always took a three hour nap
in the afternoon he said that way he got
a day and a half's worth of work out of
every day he got the full amount of
sleep but he divided into two pieces
here's the caffeine one so caffeine does
help but now you say well shoot you know
I think I'm going to take it kind of
easy this semester and I'll just work
hard during the week before finals
maybe I'll go twenty would bother
sleeping up for the 24 hours before the
603 for file it's okay well let's see
what will happen let's work the numbers
here's 24 hours and that's where your
effectiveness is is after 24 hours now
let's go over to the same amount of
effectiveness on the blood alcohol curve
and it's about the level at which you
would be legally drunk so I guess what
we ought to do is check everybody as
they come into the 603 for final and
arrest you if you spend 24 hours without
sleep and not like to take any finals
again for a year so if you do all that
you might as well to get drunk and now
we have one thing left to do today and
that is addressed the original question
of why it is that all the dogs and cats
in the world think that the diet drink
makes people fat what's the answer
it's because only fat guys like me drink
this crap so since the dogs and cats
don't have the ability to tell
themselves stories don't have that
capacity to string together events into
narratives they don't have any way of
saying well this is a consequence of
desiring not to be fat not a quenched
consequence of being cut they don't have
that story and so what they're doing is
something had to be very careful about
and that thing you have to be very
careful about is the confusion of
correlation with cause they see the
correlation but they don't understand
the cost so that's why they make a
mistake
you